there wasn't much cash brought to the
table by the saints to keep
jameis winston his base value on his
contract about five and a half million
he can make more than 12 million in
incentives he had a
media availability on tuesday i believe
it was i can't keep my day straight this
time of year but jameis winston
among other things spoke about his
relationship with drew brees this is
powerful powerful stuff
have a listen to what jameis winston had
to say about his one year
with drew brees in new orleans
well that moment to me was
like being able to have
an entire season
with drew brees
was a dream of mine like
and for him to put his arm around me or
you know
just give me any any encouraging words
after i saw the resilience
the passion the way that he went
approached every single day but that to
even be a story like i was
i was touched by that because he doesn't
even know how much he means to me
and my family for real
but i'm not gonna share what you shared
with me
i don't even remember but he touched me
ben having a chance to play in the
playoffs
after like
winning the playoff game like getting a
chance to throw a touchdown in the
playoffs like
i love football that's all i i've done
my entire life
and someone that i look up to that i
admire
that i actually could touch
was my teammate and i had a chance to
serve him
like man this i'm speechless that like
they get
that really gets me emotional because i
really love drew brees like
i don't think he understands i know my
wife do i know
my family do but
yeah i don't understand the impact that
him
and a lot of other quarterbacks had on
me
as a quarterback growing up
in bessemer alabama and y'all don't
never understand like a lot of people
don't understand that human aspect to an
athlete
but nah man
just know i love you breeze for real
like i really do
and uh i was just happy that i was able
to
to witness what he did
that was amazing yeah i was blown away
by that we had it last night on pftpm it
blew me away then
seeing it again today it blows me away
i'm impressed with
the the passion and the emotion coming
from jameis winston
and it just shows you what an impact
drew brees has on his teammates
when that's the impact that he had on
a guy who wasn't even on the field with
him except on that gadget play
when he threw the touchdown pass in the
playoff game i think drew was still on
the field for that yeah he was
yeah so uh i i lo i don't know who the
starting quarterback is going to be for
the saints but you know what sean
payton's got two
that he can choose from yeah and two
that he can use interchangeably
and we know how this goes he's going to
keep it quiet he's going to maybe put
out some misinformation
and we'll find out come week one who his
quarterback is yeah we'll see and he's
going to let them compete i mean it's
gonna
that's the one thing you know with sean
payton too it's gonna be a real
competition like yeah taysom hill might
get to start with the first team you
know the first week and do
all that but i you know it's not gonna
be like one of those like hey it's a
competition i'm saying that
but i continually let one guy be the
starter
and show the team that he's really the
starter even though we're saying
competition
you know out there out loud in in media
sessions and things like that
i think it will be real taysom hill's
gonna have to earn it
i think he's gonna have to earn it too
just because you you want to make it
look like the guy earned it
you know to the rest of your football
team you know it's one of those things
again you got to be careful about
anointing the guy the starter and then
james winston goes out there more days
of the week and dominates practice or
also
all of a sudden has a pre-season game
and now your team's going
what the hell is going on there um but
what did you want to say something of
that i thought
no no i no i i you're absolutely right
you have to have credibility in the law
you can't prop up taysom hill if james
winston is clearly the better guy no
that's the question yeah here's the
question is this a true competition
where it goes to the best guy even if
it's only by a little bit
or do you think that the taysom hill
contract and the history
gives him an advantage where if it's
close it goes to him
i think if it's close it goes to him
because of that you're right i do i
think if it's a close
it'll go to taysom hill because of he's
been there
he's been a good saint he is sean
payton's you know
pet project and all of those type of
things to where if it's really close i
think taysom hill gets the benefit of
the doubt
you know and i think the team can rally
behind that again
hey the team's gonna go into the year
two going wait can taste them hill
really be the guy as he really
so they're gonna want to see him prove
it in training camp in preseason and do
all that stuff too
you know it's it's a different year you
know to be the guy
instead of like hey i'm the cool little
toy that comes in and
you know can do some different things
than than drew brees there's not a lot
of pressure in that type of situation
um but yeah i expect to see a real
competition and and you know back to
what james winston said there
you know that that is amazing i mean it
really is
you know you could tell he's touched in
general he he probably feels like
hey he's got a second you know life and
football
a second chance here to make something
and you know i was fortunate to see a
guy who won a super bowl my rookie year
right off the bat but when you're a guy
like jameis winston
who's really not been around a guy like
that
in his years in tampa you know as much
as he
thought you know i'm i'm a pr i'm
approaching practice in a professional
manner and i'm
i'm doing meetings and i'm really about
my business
you know it's when you get around guys
like drew brees or aaron rodgers or
peyton manning or tom brady or those
kind of guys
you start to go damn i'm not doing
enough
i i didn't realize what they do
to be so awesome all the time i thought
i was doing what i needed to do
but you know there's those times where
you need
you know a coach or a player to kind of
show you the way
not everybody comes in the league
knowing how to be a professional and how
to approach it
and that's what's important and that to
me that seems where like jameis winston
gets
you know real emotional because i think
it's probably changed his
outlook on the game and how he has to
approach the position
and he's just so happy that he's gonna
get a chance and then that he got to
learn from drew brees this is pretty
damn special
yeah it's been a master class for him
and it reminds me of when he was at the
pro bowl for the first time and he was
loading up his plate with eggs and bacon
and breakfast and stuff
russell wilson and someone else coming
back from a workout that was his
epiphany
that if i'm going to be serious about
this i got to bust my butt
all the time and think about historical
comparisons and i'm having a hard time
coming up with one yeah
where and this speaks to the motivation
that jameis winston should have going
forward
right he is playing for a team in the
same division
as the franchise that made him the first
overall pick in the draft
that kept him for five years that
brought in a coach hand-picked coach to
get the most out of jameis winston
that coach threw him overboard after a
year brought in tom brady
won a super bowl beat the saints in the
playoffs
to get there if that isn't motivation
for jameis winston to do everything he
can
to win the job so he can beat the
buccaneers every chance he gets and
out compete them that's his real
competition it's not taysom hill
it's the tampa bay buccaneers i i can't
think of another time
and maybe there's one out there that i'm
not thinking of and if anyone
if anyone thinks of it go ahead and
email it to us florio
profootballtalk.com or tweet it to us
where there's a quarterback who was
rejected
ultimately by the team that drafted him
and he's there in the division
yeah he's got a chance to be the
starting quarterback into my head drew
bledsoe right
with buffalo bills but no mike i mean
your point's still real
i can remember that with drew bledsoe
and the bills remember and i think they
played the opening game that next year
and the bills
you know laid it to the new england
patriots and blew them out
the lawyer malloy that was that's a
that's a year you're a year off i mean
you're off
okay that was 2003. but 2002
was the year that he played for the
bills after being traded for a first
round pick
okay when tom brady became the guy after
winning the super bowl so rare
he was he was part of that team and got
kicked to the curb at least he got his
ring
right for that team and he got to play
how he led the team to the super bowl he
tom brady got injured in pittsburgh and
and bledsoe carried them to the afc
championship
this is winston getting thrown overboard
a year before
they develop a super bowl winner and now
he's in position
where he can be the giant killer and
he's got to win the starting job before
he can do it but i'm just saying what
motive
think about that motivation i was their
guy
and then i wasn't and they won a super
bowl without me and now i got a chance
to be the starting quarterback against
their top rival
and keep them from doing it again i'm
just just speaking
skill everything else that that's a
different conversation the motivation
that is there
the the thing that will get him out of
bed every day or should get him out of
bed every day between now and the start
of football season
i can't think of better motivation than
that for jameis winston no and i i
suspect sean payton's already had that
conversation oh
i'm sure i mean sean payton we know he's
feisty he's he's probably all
in on that he you know i mean he's
probably waking up every day going
man i want to shove it up these
buccaneers butts i'm so sick of hearing
this crap
i mean that's just the way he is i mean
he's edgy
so yeah they're gonna they're gonna be a
motivated football team
in general and you're right jameis
winston is gonna be highly motivated by
a lot of different things certainly
um but i'm excited i'm excited to see
what he can do
you know if he does get that chance to
be the starter and again
it's one of those things too where we
talked about it a lot i mean
it's you know backup quarterback for
taysom hill
the way he plays the game you know i
would think more likely than not
you're gonna get a chance to play at
some point during the year and i'm not
wishing anything bad on taysom hill i
really like him i'm rooting for him
i think he's got big time talent he can
do some special things there's no doubt
about that
but but jameis winston whether you win
the job or not be ready to go
because we know we saw taysom he'll get
banged up a little last year he's been
banged up a few times the last few years
uh but now this year he's got to play
quarterback every week if he wins the
job so
hopefully jameis will be ready to go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports